Overcoming rejections from investors
is something all entrepreneurs do.
Google, LinkedIn, all those
founders got rejected dozens and
dozens of times before they
got their first investment.
So if you get rejected, good news!
You're part of a great
group of entrepreneurs, and
it's actually part of the process.
I think the key is to
learn from each rejection.
Why were you rejected?
Maybe you didn't approach the right
investors in the first place.
Maybe your pitch was too long or
not clear enough.
Try to get that feedback from
the investor as to how to improve it and
improve your chances of raising
funding with other investors.